Cool.
So yeah, this is basically
what it's going to be,
just the grid layout.
I took the colors, actually,
from the app, the hex colors.
So they're actually
the hex colors.
And yeah.
Basically, also changing
this input to be down here.
Just make it a little bit closer
to what the actual app is.
So we can stop this.
Cool.
And so basically, when
going through this,
seeing the original
app, I always
use testy for some reason.
Because "test" is
not five letters.
Right?
Winston built it
with a verbatim text
output, which is easy and good.
But if we want to
style it, we're
going to start wanting to get
it into HTML dom elements.
And so basically, taking
this result output here.
And instead of having it be
verbatim text output we're
going to do, uiOutput.
Output.
Call it result also.
Comma.
And then, we can get rid of
this verbatim text output.
And so that itself should work.
It just doesn't give you
the-- it's just text.
But that works,
just replacing that.
But what we
eventually want to do
is, get it into a bunch
of individual divs
so that we can put a nice
border around each letter,
color it, do all that stuff.
So right now, the
way that it works,
output result is a renderText.
We're going to need
to change that.
And looks like there's a
vapply that makes a character.
So it's basically assuming
it's a character vector.
And then, it pastes
everything together here.
So what we are going to do
is, make this not a vapply,
but an lapply so that
it can just be a list.
By doing that, we need
to get rid of this.
And then, format_result, just
to make sure it's working.
We can just wrap it in the
div, tags div function.
Save that.
We can run it.
But it gives us this output.
And that's just because we're
still doing this paste here.
So we can get rid of that
by just returning out_str.
Reload it.
Now we're getting an error.
That's because, like I said,
we need to change this.
Because right now,
render text is
trying to paste
everything together
because it says I'm
putting out text.
And we are just giving
it a list of divs,
so that's not going to work.
It's now working.
This is a div.
We can check that,
though, to make sure.
Just do an in-line style.
I like to do outline
as my default,
check to see if
something is working.
So I do outline
1px solid salmon,
because it's my
favorite CSS color.
And so we see, we are
indeed getting a div.
The div has the
whole guess in it.
So we can do "shiny"
as our second guess.
So we get two divs.
They're stacking on
top of each other.
That's good.
Pretty much what we want.
But in here, the
div body is still
just this text pasted together.
So we should update
format_result,
because div takes
that as the input.
So we need to make this
not return just a string,
but return a list of divs.
So we can do this by writing
our loops in a for loop
over the letters
in a given guess.
And so builds this out_str.
So we're going to replace
out_str with out_divs.
We're going to make that a
taglist, which is basically
just a fancy list that
works well with the tags,
like div and stuff.
And then, in here,
you can say, out_divs.
The ith element is going
to be equal to a new div.
It is this internal
section here.
So we can pull that out.
Pull that out.
Use the braces there.
And then, last, this
one just has spaces.
Get rid of all of
these out strings.
I have just returned
[INAUDIBLE]..
And so in theory,
this should now--
yep.
So now it's behaving differently
because by default, divs
themselves like to stack
on top of each other.
They don't go in line.
It's because they're a
block-level CSS element,
so that basically
says, the next one,
I'm going down instead of over.
But one of the things
that we can do here
is, put some style around this.
So we could say, instead
of making a bunch of divs,
we could just do the
[AUDIO OUT] one time--
bring this down here--
and have this if statement
give us the inside text.
So we'd say,
letterText equals that.
And then, just bring
these back to pastes.
So the idea here
is to do a single--
no, well, not that--
do a single div call.
So that way, we can do
stuff like put a class on it
without having to repeat
that class a million times.
So that should be good.
We don't need to do
the assignment here,
these assignments.
So then, once we've assigned
letterText in this--
indent that-- this if
statement assigns letterText
based on how we
did the result. So
that we can just
take that letterText
and put it in this
div, just quickly.
Make sure it worked.
OK, looks like it worked.
So then, can do some
in-line styles here.
So we'll do, outline
1px solid blanchedalmond
is another good CSS color.
OK, so now we can see,
we had this wrapping div.
Each individual
letter within here
is taking up the whole span.
That's because of
these block elements.
So I think a good
way to proceed,
since we want that grid, we want
them to sit next to each other,
we could just try,
width is 50 pixels.
Height, 50 pixels.
Just see what this gives us.
OK, so they're boxes now,
but they're still stacked.
So I guess if we wanted to make
them sit next to each other
like they should, there's a few
different ways we can do this.
I think the way
that I want to do
it, just because I am familiar
with it, is to use CSS grid.
So CSS grid is basically
a way of saying,
I want you to lay this stuff
out in a different way.
And you can say, I want to
fill in this many columns
and this many rows.
And so this works
really well here,
because we know we
have five columns.
And so we can start doing that.
But first, we should probably--
right now, we're building our
styles in these in-line styles.
And that works fine for
just a couple of things.
But it's going to get pretty
unwieldy very quickly.
So what we can do
is, include some CSS.
And there's a bunch of
different ways to do this.
The easiest way is
to just put the stuff
in the head of the UI.
So that's tags$head.
Says, anything that
goes within this
gets placed into the head of
the UI HTML that's generated,
which is part of the page
that doesn't actually show up,
but you can put resources like
CSS and JavaScript in there.
Doesn't really matter.
Just know that you
have to put your style.
So you can do
tags.style within that.
And then, from there, there's
one more thing you have
to remember-- and this bites
me every time I do this--
is that you have to wrap this--
because we're going to write it
in text, in line--
to wrap it in this
HTML function.
And that just allows
us to use characters
that CSS likes, such as
the less than or greater
than signs, which would,
by default, get translated
into weird Unicode
character things.
But CSS actually wants them.
So we need to wrap
it in HTML, or we
will have very
confusing bugs that will
take a long time to understand.
So in theory,
tags$head, tags$style,
now we can just start
writing CSS in there,
and it'll apply to page.
So we could test that,
again, by targeting
this result, because the
uiOutput creates a div that
shoves all of your UI into it.
And then, the ID of that
is the ID that you give it.
So we can target
that real quick.
Could say, CSS rule targeting
result. And say, let's see,
background color.
Just another-- since
we're already using
outlines, let's use
background color.
And for background color,
we can do light-grey.
I believe that's the right way.
So see if this works.
Did not.
OK, so background
color light-grey
is probably not the right one.
Let's just do steelblue.
There we go.
OK.
So this is div result, which
contains all of our stuff,
has background.
So we're successfully targeting
it with this CSS rule.
So what we're going to do is, go
back and do this CSS Grid stuff
so that we can get it to
lay out how we want it to.
Because we have each
letter being a div,
we want them to sit,
five next to each other,
and then wrap down
to the next row.
So for each guess.
So we could do, display, grid.
Which is how you say,
OK, this div, within it,
use the grid layout engine.
And then, we can do,
grid-template-columns.
Repeat.
So we're saying, repeat
this thing five times.
5, and 50 pixels.
So that's saying,
make me a grid that
has columns that are defined
as five columns of 50 pixels.
This is a syntax that's
kind of hard to understand.
And I know it because I
work with it all the time.
But there's a really
good resource,
which is this complete guide
to CSS Grid, which is where
I go for almost everything.
It gives you all
sorts of things.
So if you [AUDIO OUT] forget
anything with CSS Grid,
this is a fantastic
resource for it.
So going back
here, we're saying,
it's going to be a grid.
It's going to have five
columns, each 50 pixels wide.
So we can save and reload.
And it's not doing
what we want it to.
But interestingly,
there is a border
around this that is the color
that we put of this div.
That's right, it's
the salmon border.
And so we actually
don't want that div.
We just want the results
dumped right in there.
So we can just get rid
of that div in general
so that all of our divs--
yeah, there we go.
So we were wrapping it in a div.
And CSS Grid says,
I'm going to--
I don't know about the children.
I only care about
the first child.
I don't care about the
children of your children.
So the div within
it will be a column.
And then, the next one is
another column, and so on.
But right in the way
that we were doing,
it we were wrapping all of
the letters in a single div.
And so it didn't actually know
to put them how we want them.
But now it is.
And so now we see five values
in their little boxes here.
We can do another
guess, just to see
if it wraps how we want it to.
Let's get shiny.
It does.
So now we have five.
New guess down here.
Five.
And all we're doing is
building these divs.
And so what we should do
now is, obviously, this text
is up in the upper left.
And that's not great.
So we need to target
these individual divs.
And before, what we were
doing is, this in-line styles.
But that's not
great, so we're going
to take that out and bring
it back up to our CSS chunk.
So we can call--
there's a couple of
ways we could do this.
We could say-- we could
give this div a class
itself and then refer
to that class up here.
Or we could say,
result, and then, div.
Which is saying, of
all of the divs that
are children of result, this
is the style I want to apply.
But I think that
what we want to do
is, make a new class, just to
be a little bit more readable.
So we could say, guess-letter.
Then we're going to paste in
that style that we had before.
Save that.
We need to go down here
and put the div class in.
But let's run it without
that first, just to see.
So yeah, we get, they're
laid out in that order,
but they don't have the style.
So now, in theory, to get that
style back, we should just say,
class equals guess-letter.
So that should give this div
the class of guest-letter.
So that should apply this.
Let's see if it works.
Did.
OK, cool.
So now, we want to
style these guys,
we can just do it right
there, which is nice.
So within that, we could
say, first thing, I think,
we're going to
want to do is, put
this actual letter in
the center of the box
so it's not wasting
all that space.
So there's a bunch
of different ways
to center something in CSS.
It's one of those problems
in computer science,
along with caching,
aligning stuff in CSS.
But the easiest way to
do it that I'm aware of
is to do, display, grid.
So say, this child element
also has a display grid.
And then, place content, center.
And that basically just
centers everything completely
within the div.
So now, we have everything
perfectly centered.
So that's nice.
So it's starting to look
a little bit better.
One thing that we can do to
make it a little bit more
like the Wordle thing is
have them not butted up right
against each other.
So there's a property
on the grid, CSS Grid.
It's called gap.
So we say, gap.
And we'll set it to 5 pixels.
So that's basically saying,
place these items of the grid
five pixels away
from each other.
Cool.
So now they have that gap.
It's getting better.
We could round the
edges a little bit
and say, border-radius.
Also say that's 5 pixels.
So that should just say--
I'm going to round the edges.
Oh, but I did it wrong.
Oh, you know what?
I need to do,
border, not outline.
Border radius, border.
There we go.
Border, on newer
browsers, the outline
will respect this border radius.
But on older browsers, such as
the built-in viewer in RStudio,
you need to use the border.
Which is kind of confusing,
that there's border and outline.
But, just, there
is at this point.
So now that we have that,
things are looking pretty good.
Stuff is working.
But I think the next
step is going to be--
right now, we're
using this indicator
of wrapped-in parentheses means
that it's in the wrong place.
But in the word and
then square brackets,
mean that it's correct.
So that's probably
not the best way
to do that given that the actual
Wordle app does it in color.
So we should start
doing it in color.
And we're going to do
that with another class.
So if we notice, down
here, the way, though,
our results come, each
thing has a result.
And it's either correct
in word or not in word.
And so if we use that,
we can use that directly
as a class on our div itself.
So within here, format_result.
Class is going to be
paste of guess-letter.
And then, also,
the result itself.
In that, we reload the app.
I'm going to pop this out
into the browser real quick so
that we can use the
inspect panel, just
to see if this is working.
So we can see now,
this element here, this
s, is a div with the class
of guess-letter and in-word.
So now that we
have that class, we
can use our CSS, like
we were doing before,
to target it and make
it look how it should.
So we could just say, .in-word.
And I believe-- let's see.
In the Wordle app, he
uses an orange for that.
So we could say, in-word
background color is orangered.
It's a little bit more
intense than we maybe want,
but let's try that.
Cool.
So now that's colored correctly.
There's the
not-in-word, I believe,
is the other class that we have.
Yeah, not-in-word.
So the other letters here.
not-in-word.
Background color,
call lightgrey.
I think I did it
right this time,
where light gray does
not have a hyphen.
Let's fix this indentation.
But it's just one single word.
Wonderful.
So we can get rid of
that border that's
getting really distracting.
And then, we should probably
say, color is white.
Then, color on a element.
Confusingly, not the
background color.
That's set with background
color, where background color
is the color of the text.
So this should-- when we have
these darker background colors,
we kind of want white.
Maybe gray is not
the right color.
We should use something
darker, like just pure gray.
OK.
So now we see, the letter
pops out a little bit.
I think we should increase the
size of the font a little bit.
So do, font-size.
Maybe make it 20 pixels.
Cool.
Looking better.
We still have this
decoration here.
Actually, we should
figure out a letter
that is in the correct place.
Why is that not a valid guess?
Oh, it's not a
valid word, is it?
Interesting.
So s has to be at the end.
OK, s is sitting
here, but hidden,
because I haven't styled it.
Fun.
So correct, I think, is the
style we need to give it.
Correct, yes.
OK, so now, that can be
done. background-color,
do forest green.
It's a good one.
Reload app.
Tests.
Wonderful.
Still have this-- see if we
could figure out a word that
has--
let's just do, "shiny," to see.
OK, so we still have
this decoration there.
So we need to get rid of that.
Or we should get rid of that,
just to make it look nicer.
The nice thing about
this is that this whole
if loop that we were doing here
before, we don't need it all,
we just need the letter.
So we can just take that
letter, put it there,
and get rid of that.
So simpler code.
Reload the app.
Wonderful.
So that is starting
to actually look
like the correct
stuff, which is nice.
So I guess one thing
that we need to fix now
is the fact that this legend
doesn't mean anything anymore.
So we should fix that.
So this is just text here.
This means that the
letter is correct.
So what we can do is, we
can use a span element.
And class equals guess-letter.
OK, and I think that this is
going to be a bit much, though,
because--
then we'll say, means
the letter is correct.
So correct.
This is going to
make this 50 by 50.
And that's not what we want.
Yeah, so that's a
little bit too big.
So we should figure out
how to get this sizing not
specifically tied to that.
So all this sizing stuff.
Width, 50 pixels, height, 50
pixels, font size, 20 pixels.
We only want that to apply
to this result board.
But we still want to be able to
use this other stuff down here.
So I'm going to use the CSS
rule that I talked about before.
Which is, we can say of
the result, anything that
is a child of it that has
the class guess-letter,
there, we can put these styles.
And that means those
styles should only
apply to the guess-letters that
are a child of this results
div.
Oof.
Oh, wait.
We get this now.
So that's not great.
You probably also want to
put this grid stuff here.
OK, there we go.
So now, X, it's still not great.
So maybe we should
do padding, 4 pixels.
Padding just basically
says, give me
some space around the
content within this element.
So yeah, there we go.
I think that's good
enough, pretty much.
And so we can now replace
this other one down here.
span X, class equals
guess-letter and in-word.
That's the class, comma.
Cool.
So that now our legend matches.
There's a little bit of--
I don't like this is
butting up against that.
So we can fix that
pretty easily,
because we know that we
have this result div.
So we could just say, let's
put padding on that thing too.
So padding is 15 pixels.
So that should give
us 15 pixels of space.
Cool.
So that looks pretty good.
I think, right now, this
input stuff is above it.
But in the actual
Wordle, it's below it.
So we should move it down.
So it's a text input.
It should be as simple as
just dropping it down there.
Reload app.
Cool.
We still have this.
So maybe we want to put
it beneath that too.
Look at that app.
Cool.
It's looking pretty good.
I think I really
[AUDIO OUT] Go button
to be next to it
instead of beneath it.
So actually, you know what?
Maybe first, we will--
right now,
everything's shoved up
against the left of
the screen, but I
think that's a little
bit maybe not the best.
So we want to basically make
everything sit in the center.
On a phone, it'll
be like it is now.
But on a big screen
like the viewer right
here, that's not ideal.
But to do that, we need
to go back into the HTML.
And I want to see, how are we
going to target this whole app?
So we have the
body of the thing.
And then, we have this div.
And that div contains
the whole app.
And its class is
container-fluid.
Which makes sense, because we're
using this fluid page here.
And so what we can do is, target
this container-fluid class
and just give it
a maximum width.
And that should keep
things nice and centered.
So I say, container-fluid.
Fluid.
And then, max-- you know,
let's start with width.
Width is 500 pixels.
So now, things are pretty much
in the center, which is nice.
That's the nice thing.
Fluid page will automatically
keep itself centered,
which is nice.
If it didn't, we would have to
[INAUDIBLE] control [AUDIO OUT]
that.
The problem that we run into is,
equals, that will cause issues.
And so we don't
actually want width.
We want max width.
And so max width says, follow
the width of the page--
the width of your iPhone screen
or your computer screen--
unless that's bigger
than 500 pixels.
So most of the time, that's
going to be bigger than 500
pixels.
But in the case
where it's smaller,
it will let it shrink,
at least in theory.
So let's just to see if that
does what I said it would.
So yeah, it's shrinking now.
It's not letting
itself get too big.
So that's nice.
So cool.
It's looking pretty
good right now.
I think one thing
we might want to do
is, this board screen
is not centered.
We're just going to give
ourselves some context.
This helps to view what's
going on in the app
so we can decide if
something is centered.
So it's not centered.
So we can try to
make it centered.
And that's justify-content.
This is another one
of those-- you have
to look it up a million times.
I got it right on
the first guess.
I'd almost never done that.
If you look at that
CSS Grid cheat sheet,
there's a bunch
of different ways
to align the things
in your grid.
And yeah, so here we go.
So justify.
And you can justify as self.
We could justify items.
So you get lucky, basically.
Almost no one ever remembers it.
But I got lucky and
remembered it there.
So now, this is lined up, which
the way that it should be.
So that's good.
Let's do one more guess,
just to make sure.
Cool, it's working
how it should.
That's nice.
So I think the last
thing that I want to do
is, fix this input so that the
input is the Go button that's
here, because we're just
kind of wasting space.
So to do that like
we had before,
when we had the letters
that just stacked
on top of each other, it's
because they're just this block
setup.
We don't actually let
them know that we want
them to be next to each other.
And so we can
group them together
just by wrapping them in a div.
So we can say, div.
This is just [INAUDIBLE].
Bring them up into that div.
So this shouldn't change
anything right now.
It didn't.
So they're still right there.
Let's give this div a class so
that we can start targeting it
with our CSS.
Say, input wrapper.
Make sure that we're--
take that input wrapper
down here-- .input wrapper.
outline 1px solid.
Let's just do forest green.
There's only so many CSS
colors I can keep in my head.
Cool.
So now we see that we
do have this div there.
And we have the individual
elements within it.
So like we did before, we
could do, display, grid.
See what that gives us.
Does not exactly do
what we might want.
But let's do a different way.
Let's do display, flex.
And Flexbox is another
layout algorithm.
Now they're next to each other.
Flexbox is,
basically, if you want
to line things up
next to each other
and make them align
in the proper way,
Flexbox is what you want to use.
So this is a kind of a
perfect scenario for Flexbox.
So a couple of things stand
out as not good right now.
One is, the Go button is
really tall compared to this.
And then, also, they're
right up next to each other.
I don't think we want
them next to each other.
So let's do that same
way of selecting a child.
So we could say, input wrapper.
And then, button,
which is the element,
selecting a button element.
We could just say,
margin left, and give it
something like 10 pixels.
So in theory, that
should take this button
and basically make it
10 pixels from the thing
that it's closest
to on the left.
Did.
So that's nice.
So that's better.
But now, I don't like that
they're like this at all.
That's kind of gross.
So what we can do is, go
into our browser's DevTools.
Because just like
CSS Grid, CSS Flexbox
has all sorts of fun settings
that no one ever remembers.
But the DevTools
tools within Chrome
have a nice little tool
for working with them.
So you can do things
like align your content.
And you just play with this
little thing right here,
and make it look
like want it to.
So let's do-- that centered it.
So I would say,
justify-content, space around.
align-content doesn't
do anything for us.
So we can kind of
just ignore it.
align-item center.
So now they're pretty
close to being centered.
So I'm going to copy
this CSS from here.
Put it here so I don't forget
it, because I will forget it.
Quickly make sure that it works.
OK, it did.
Let's go back in here again.
That looks pretty good.
But if you're like
me, you're going
to get driven insane by the
fact that this button is not
actually lined up with
the input, the text input.
And that's because you can
see that there's this weird--
there's a margin on the bottom
of that input that is not
on the bottom of the button.
And so that causes
it to be misaligned.
And so what we can do
is, since we already
have something targeting
the button, go back in here,
look at this.
So it's a shiny input
container form group.
It's a div.
So what we could do is, say,
let me get, in my input-wrapper,
div.
So this is saying, I'm
going to target the div that
is the child of input-wrapper.
So that should be
this text input.
And then we could just
say, margin-bottom is 0.
Don't need to put
pixels or anything,
because zero doesn't need units.
Reload it.
And now it sticks there.
So at least it's lined
up on the bottom.
I think we do
align-items, flex-end.
And this-- OK.
So flex-end says, in
your vertical alignment
of these items in this
box, put it at the end.
You have to prefix
it with flex here,
because older
browsers need that.
Newer browsers, you
could just say, end.
They also understand flex-end.
So it's safe to put that there.
So now, we pretty
much got what we want.
They're lined up
how we want them.
And then, we can--
actually, justify-content space
around is not what we want,
because we already
spaced those things out.
So let's put it,
justify-content as center.
So now they're centered.
The button, the space that we
already did with our margin,
is there.
So that's nice.
And then, we've just
got to get rid of this.
There's a space on the top of
this, but not on the bottom.
So we dealt with that before
by putting padding on it.
So let's just say, padding--
we only need padding
on the bottom here.
10 pixels.
Cool.
And then, take out this outline.
And OK, let's see.
Run tests.
That is looking pretty decent.
We got to fix-- got to get
rid of that one outline
that I was so eagerly adding.
Now we're-- helps to actually
look at it how it will be,
just to make sure that there's
not some weird CSS funkiness
going on.
So that's pretty good.
I think the thing
that I would do next
is, these colors are not right.
That's orange-red is like
very in-your-face aggressive.
So I will just go and use this
handy-dandy CSS inspector tool
that I've been using.
Go to the Wordle app.
Daily word game.
And so we see that
these are the colors.
And we can just do
that Inspect Element.
And then, background color
of our color, correct.
But there's an easier way
to [AUDIO OUT] colors.
Or some might say, steal colors.
So we use this, you see?
This little eyedropper.
Put that eyedropper
over something.
It'll show up the
color right there.
We can copy that.
So forest green gets
replaced by this hex color.
And then, the gray that
he uses is this hex color.
And last, this is
hardly an orange.
It's more like goldenrod, maybe.
Use that.
Reload it.
That looks correct.
So cool.
I think that's pretty good.
Maybe one thing that we could
do is make the text bold.
So font-weight, bold.
Make it pop out a
little bit more.
Kind of gets lost as a--
cool.
I think that gets us pretty far.
We could tackle this keyboard,
but we would basically
just repeat the same steps
that we did for this.
Just turn everything into a
div and lay it out properly.